Lucia: 没找着哎
Lucia: I couldn't find it.
Katrina:  这是做装饰吗
Katrina: Is this for decoration?
Katrina:  哪一个
Katrina: Which one?
Lucia: 对那个是做装饰
Lucia: Yes, that one is for decoration.
Lucia: 稍等
Lucia: Hold on.
Lucia: 嗯哪一个什么
Lucia: Hmm, which one are you talking about?
Lucia: 这个
Lucia: This one.
Katrina:   还要什么
Lucia: 哦你说的是哎
Lucia: Oh, you mean that, right?
Lucia: 不是这个吧哎
Lucia: It's not this one, right?
Lucia: 啊我看见裱花袋了
Lucia: Ah, I see the piping bag.
Lucia: 但是裱花嘴是哪个
Lucia: But which one is the piping tip?
Katrina:  什么叫裱花袋
Katrina: What do you mean by piping bag?
Lucia: 这个但是裱花嘴我没看到
Lucia: This one, but I didn't see the piping tip.
Tasha: 嗯我是这个可以拿出来了
Tasha: Hmm, can I take this out now?
Tasha: 你来拿着吗
Tasha: Are you going to hold it?
Tasha: 你带着眼镜
Tasha: You're wearing glasses.
Tasha: 我老行好好的
Tasha: I always do things well.
Katrina:  我把这个叉子放回去
Katrina: I'll put this fork back.
Lucia: 但我还没找到那个裱花嘴
Lucia: But I still haven't found the piping tip.
Lucia: 大家快来观摩一下好漂亮
Lucia: Everyone, come and take a look. It's so pretty.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Lucia: 大家都好厉害
Lucia: Everyone is amazing.
Lucia: 啊哎呦
Lucia: Ah, oops.
Lucia: 不好意思
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia: 这个我就放在哎
Lucia: I'll just put this here, oops.
Lucia: 这是刚才从哪拿过来的来着
Lucia: Where did I take this from earlier?
Lucia: 这吗洗在哪
Lucia: Here? Where do we wash this?
Lucia: 呃什么洗
Lucia: Uh, what to wash?
Lucia: 裱花嘴哦
Lucia: The piping tip, oh.
Lucia: 那个我刚才也没找到
Lucia: I couldn't find it earlier either.
Lucia: 你说裱花袋也在这
Lucia: You said the piping bag is here.
Lucia: 我看到了
Lucia: I saw it.
Lucia: 但是裱花嘴我也没看到
Lucia: But I didn't see the piping tip.
Lucia: 今天应该把它拿出来
Lucia: We should have taken it out today.
Lucia: 他洗的对
Lucia: He washed it, right.
Jake: 我洗的嗯
Jake: I washed it, hmm.
Lucia: 哈哈你回忆一下
Lucia: Haha, try to remember.
Lucia: 回忆回忆
Lucia: Think, think.
Jake: 难道在这个地方
Jake: Could it be in this place?
Jake: 这些地方
Jake: In these places.
Jake: 不能啊
Jake: No, you can't.
Jake: 不能够
Jake: You can't.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 这里面也没有
Lucia: There's nothing in here either.
Lucia: 这应该是
Lucia: This should be...
Lucia: 就是就是普通的磨具
Lucia: Just an ordinary mold.
Jake: 很奇怪没有一点线索呢
Jake: It's strange, there's no clue at all.
Jake: 我应该不会扔了吧
Jake: I shouldn't have thrown it away, right?
Lucia: 哎找到了
Lucia: Oh, found it!
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Lucia: 嗯？
Lucia: Huh?
Tasha: 那是转换器
Tasha: That's the converter.
Lucia: 哦OK
Lucia: Oh, OK.
Jake:裱花嘴
Jake: Piping tip.
Jake:是什么
Jake: What is it?
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake:你的还有一会
Jake: Yours will take a while.
Jake:你的得有个十分钟吧
Jake: Yours will take about ten minutes.
Lucia: 我站这边
Lucia: I'll stand over here.
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh my.
Lucia: 这给他穿过去啊
Lucia: This goes through here, right?
Lucia: 好香啊
Lucia: Smells so good.
Lucia: 稍等一下
Lucia: Just a moment.
Lucia: 我把这个擦一下
Lucia: Let me wipe this off.
Lucia: 弄下来
Lucia: Take it down.
Lucia: OK我是不是一会得把裤子洗下去
Lucia: OK, should I wash my pants later?
Katrina: 哦不是说有洗衣机吗
Katrina: Oh, isn't there a washing machine?
Jake:对在这
Jake: Yes, it's over here.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Lucia: 没事没事
Lucia: It's okay, it's okay.
Katrina: 我可能也要洗
Katrina: I might need to wash too.
Lucia: 哎呀但我要是洗的话
Lucia: Oh, if I wash it...
Lucia: 我明天我要不穿牛仔裤或者之类的啊
Lucia: Should I not wear jeans or something tomorrow?
Jake:别地方应该没有
Jake: There shouldn't be any other place.
Jake:牛仔裤跳舞
Jake: Dancing in jeans?
Lucia: 好问题如果跳什么舞还得思考半天
Lucia: Good question, if we're dancing, I need to think for a while.
Lucia: 如果要跳舞的话
Lucia: If we're dancing...
Lucia: 我有没有带合适的衣服
Lucia: Did I bring the right clothes?
Katrina: 不跳那种幅度大的话就穿裙子也可以
Katrina: If it's not a dance with big moves, you can wear a dress.
Katrina: 就你今天那个裙子
Katrina: Like the dress you wore today.
Katrina: 也可以
Katrina: That works too.
Lucia: 嗯我还有个裙子
Lucia: Hmm, I also have a dress.
Lucia: 我带了两条裙子
Lucia: I brought two dresses.
Lucia: 一会一会我们再商量商量
Lucia: We can discuss it later.
Katrina: 跳个短短的
Katrina: Let's do a short dance.
Lucia: 我觉得可以有哈哈哈哈
Lucia: I think that's a good idea, hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:什么什么样了
Jake: What, what do you mean?
Jake:什么样的服装
Jake: What kind of outfit?
Lucia: 取决于我们要跳什么舞
Lucia: It depends on what kind of dance we are doing.
Katrina: 先要确定我们跳什么类型的舞吧
Katrina: We need to decide on the type of dance first.
Katrina: 好多东西都要现
Katrina: There's a lot we need to buy.
Alice:你穿什么我就穿什么
Alice: I'll wear whatever you're wearing.
Katrina: 好多东西都要现买哦
Katrina: We need to buy a lot of things.
Katrina: 好直接逛街去
Katrina: Okay, let's go shopping directly.
Jake:逛街去可以
Jake: Going shopping sounds good.
Katrina: 戴着眼镜逛街
Katrina: Shopping with glasses on.
Alice:让我采集一下中国人类
Alice: Let me observe the Chinese people.
Lucia: 要不戴着眼镜逛淘宝吧也算是一种书
Lucia: How about we shop on Taobao with glasses on, it's also a kind of study.
Katrina: 正在逛淘
Katrina: I'm browsing Taobao.
Jake:呃可以啊
Jake: Uh, sure.
Lucia: 哎你的眼镜好了
Lucia: Hey, your glasses are fixed.
Katrina: 嗯我在看我房间装饰
Katrina: Yeah, I'm looking at room decorations.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 这好难哦
Lucia: This is so hard.
Katrina: 买一个好难
Katrina: Buying one is so hard.
Jake:突然有了某些微醺
Jake: Suddenly feeling a bit tipsy.
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yeah.
Lucia: 装饰房间
Lucia: Room decorations.
Katrina: 突然想到我小红书收藏了很久的风铃
Katrina: Suddenly thought of the wind chimes I've saved on Xiaohongshu for a long time.
Lucia: 装饰房间我说的是
Lucia: I mean room decorations.
Jake:让大家陪你一起凑单
Jake: Get everyone to help you meet the minimum order.
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia: 那我如果买热胶枪的话能报销吗
Lucia: If I buy a hot glue gun, can I get reimbursed?
Lucia: 因为假如这口不是
Lucia: Because if this mouth isn't...
Lucia: 不是不是
Lucia: No, no, no.
Lucia: 他不是很贵
Lucia: It's not very expensive.
Lucia: 他是一个手工很常见的东西
Lucia: It's a common craft tool.
Jake:行啊可以啊
Jake: Sure, that's fine.
Katrina: 热熔胶那个
Katrina: The hot melt glue thing.
Lucia: 就假如说我们要做水母灯的话
Lucia: Like if we want to make a jellyfish lamp.
Lucia: 可能会用哦
Lucia: We might use it.
Katrina: 就是那个枪那个胶是吧
Katrina: It's that gun with the glue, right?
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Katrina: 不是20块钱的
Katrina: It's not the 20 yuan one.
Lucia: 对对那个很便宜
Lucia: Yeah, that one's really cheap.
Lucia: 其实我家里有一个但是好久没用了
Lucia: Actually, I have one at home, but I haven't used it in a long time.
Lucia: 然后我没带过来
Lucia: And I didn't bring it over.
Lucia: 因为我不是很确定
Lucia: Because I wasn't sure.
Lucia: 我们具具体会不会用到它
Lucia: Whether we would actually need it.
Jake:对20块钱确实用不着批准
Jake: Yeah, for 20 yuan, you definitely don't need approval.
Tasha: 但他是捡快递的走
Tasha: But he's picking up the delivery.
Lucia: 嗯那你用刀在这里划一下就是
Lucia: Hmm, then you use the knife to make a cut here.
Lucia: 嗯嗯手小心
Lucia: Hmm, careful with your hand.
Lucia: 手要要大概要多粗笔画一下在这是吗
Lucia: Your hand needs to be roughly this thick, right?
Jake:一半
Jake: Halfway.
Lucia: 嗯再往外再往上一点这样可以吗
Lucia: Hmm, move it out a bit, up a bit. Is that good?
Lucia: 看一下
Lucia: Check it out.
Tasha: 开
Tasha: Open.
Jake:开开什么
Jake: Open what?
Lucia: 你试一下就可能要用手
Lucia: Try it, you might need to use your hand.
Lucia: 再蹬一蹬
Lucia: Push it more.
Tasha: 我拧不开必须要剪刀
Tasha: I can't open it, I need scissors.
Lucia: 嗯那怎么办呢
Lucia: Hmm, what should we do then?
Lucia: 那个剪刀够干净吗
Lucia: Are those scissors clean enough?
Jake:不不太够吧
Jake: Not really, no.
Jake:你你怎么操作的啊
Jake: How did you do it?
Jake:你怎么做的
Jake: How did you make it?
Lucia: 我要录一下啊
Lucia: I need to record this.
Tasha: 不有没有
Tasha: No, wait.
Tasha: 人要来挤
Tasha: We need to squeeze it.
Lucia: 我们先学习一下
Lucia: Let's learn it first.
Tasha: 没有什么学习的
Tasha: There's nothing to learn.
Jake:这我得学习吗
Jake: Do I need to learn this?
Lucia: 这得学得学习
Lucia: Yes, you need to learn.
Lucia: 对啊
Lucia: Yeah.
Jake:这水平很高啊
Jake: This is really high-level.
Lucia: 好有意思
Lucia: So interesting.
Lucia: 我去
Lucia: Oh my gosh.
Alice:我挤的就挤一个点的话又有啥用
Alice: What's the use if I squeeze just one spot?
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thanks
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Jake:来起一个
Jake: Let's start one
Katrina: 亲自操刀
Katrina: Do it yourself
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈多少有点奇怪
Jake: Hahaha, it's a bit weird
Lucia: 没事草莓往上一压就看不出来了
Lucia: It's okay, just press the strawberry on top and it won't show
Jake:好的
Jake: Alright
Katrina: 我来
Katrina: I'll do it
Jake:你来
Jake: You do it
Jake:最后让眼镜给个评分
Jake: Finally, let the glasses guy give a score
Lucia: 哈哈哈他有这功能吗
Lucia: Hahaha, can he do that?
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Jake:可以让他有
Jake: We can make him do it
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:真好玩
Jake: So fun
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Lucia: 为什么我不能在想断的地方把它断掉
Lucia: Why can't I break it where I want to?
Katrina: 因为断不了
Katrina: Because it won't break
Jake:挺好挺好这样挺好
Jake: It's fine, it's fine like this
Lucia: 下去你给我下去
Lucia: Get down, get down
Lucia: 但是他坠在这里
Lucia: But it's stuck here
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Lucia: 要再来一个吗
Lucia: Want to do another one?
Jake:没墨了
Jake: Out of ink
Alice:没让我弄个平
Alice: Let me make it flat
Jake:哦平一点
Jake: Oh, flatten it out
Lucia: 哇可以这个好平
Lucia: Wow, this is really flat
Lucia: 对那我再来挤一个好了
Lucia: Okay, I'll squeeze another one then
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Tasha: 挤的各有特色啊
Tasha: Each one has its own style
Tasha: 我怀疑你就这样做好了
Tasha: I suspect you're just doing it like this
Lucia: 本来想给他画个什么花
Lucia: I originally wanted to draw a flower
Lucia: 结果发现画了一个圈之后
Lucia: But after drawing a circle
Lucia: 也画不出什么了
Lucia: I couldn't draw anything else
Lucia: 这好奇怪啊
Lucia: This is so weird
Lucia: 像拔青一样
Lucia: It's like making blueprints
Katrina:  好像蜡烛
Katrina: Looks like a candle
Jake:挺好
Jake: Pretty good.
Tasha: 好了吗
Tasha: Is it done?
Lucia: 哈哈等一下
Lucia: Haha, wait a second.
Jake:这是花
Jake: This is a flower.
Katrina: 巨石阵
Katrina: Stonehenge.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 巨石阵哈哈哈
Katrina: Stonehenge, hahaha.
Lucia: 行再来一个
Lucia: Alright, one more.
Katrina: 可以画个笑脸
Katrina: You can draw a smiley face.
Tasha: 我觉得有点多
Tasha: I think it's a bit too much.
Tasha: 大家可以多挤一点
Tasha: Everyone can squeeze in a bit more.
Tasha: 最后一个
Tasha: The last one.
Jake:呵压力很大
Jake: Haha, a lot of pressure.
Tasha: 杨老板挤一个 盛大开场
Tasha: Jake, squeeze one, a grand opening.
Jake:哈哈哈压力很大
Jake: Hahaha, a lot of pressure.
Lucia: 对对对来个大的哈哈哈
Lucia: Yeah, yeah, make it a big one, hahaha.
Tasha: 嚯 怎么还剩这么多奶油
Tasha: Whoa, why is there still so much cream left?
Tasha: 那这个是不是不要了
Tasha: Should we not use this?
Tasha: 草莓
Tasha: Strawberry.
Katrina: 这个草
Katrina: This grass.
Alice:可以吃了吗
Alice: Can we eat it now?
Katrina: 草莓放冰冰上吃
Katrina: Put the strawberry on ice to eat.
Tasha: 吃
Tasha: Eat.
Katrina:  拿个小小的
Katrina: Take a small one.
Jake:压力到我这边
Jake: The pressure is on me.
Tasha: 全部挤掉
Tasha: Squeeze it all out.
Katrina: 挤满吧
Katrina: Squeeze it full.
Tasha: 这就是你了
Tasha: This is you.
Jake:挤满到我这边挤来
Jake: Squeeze it full and bring it over to me.
Lucia: 哎这还怪好看的
Lucia: Hey, this actually looks pretty good.
Katrina: 哎哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hey, hahaha.
Lucia: 果然没有压力就是不一样
Lucia: As expected, no pressure makes a difference.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 怎么办奶油太多
Tasha: What to do, there's too much cream.
Katrina: 这颜色好暗
Katrina: This color is too dark.
Lucia: 给哪个少的再加一点
Lucia: Add a bit more to the one with less.
Lucia: 如果哪位同学会吃掉他
Lucia: If anyone can eat it.
Jake:哎这样挺好
Lucia: 啊好看耶
Lucia: Ah, it looks nice.
Jake:水平还是高
Jake: The skill level is still high.
Katrina: 专业
Katrina: Professional
Jake:巨石阵批发
Jake: Stonehenge wholesale
Lucia: 巨石阵批发
Lucia: Stonehenge wholesale
Jake:哎哎这个3个变成了10个
Jake: Hey, these 3 turned into 10
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha
老板：哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Tasha: 完了完了
Tasha: Oh no, oh no
Lucia: 小心小心
Lucia: Be careful, be careful
Katrina: 喷出来了
Katrina: It's spraying out
Lucia: 主大一个不浪费
Lucia: Not wasting any of it
Alice:直接往里吸溜吧
Alice: Just slurp it up
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay
Katrina: 草莓奶油苹果
Katrina: Strawberry cream apple
Jake:拍一张
Jake: Take a picture
Tasha: 杨老板您的毅力我佩服
Tasha: Jake, I admire your perseverance
Katrina: 对拍一张
Katrina: Yeah, take a picture
Tasha: 艺术草莓
Tasha: Artistic strawberry
Jake:哈哈我的艺术草莓
Jake: Haha, my artistic strawberry
Jake:我的我的
Jake: It's mine, mine
Jake:挺好的我很开心
Jake: It's good, I'm very happy
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Tasha: 怎么这不不浪费 点的好丑啊
Tasha: Why is it not wasted, but looks so ugly?
Jake:不丑啊这个各有特色
Jake: It's not ugly, it's unique
Lucia: 对不丑不丑各有物色
Lucia: Yeah, not ugly, it's unique
Jake:真的是你远远看的
Jake: Really, from a distance
Jake:真不知道是什么哈哈哈
Jake: You can't really tell what it is, haha
Alice:我来接一个吧
Alice: Let me have one
Lucia: 我先把我点的这个跟巨石阵一样
Lucia: I'll eat this one I made like Stonehenge
Lucia: 给吃了吧
Lucia: I'll eat it
Katrina: 再不要这个
Katrina: Don't want this one anymore
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm
Tasha: 您的艺术
Tasha: Your art
Jake:谢谢谢谢您
Jake: Thank you, thank you
Katrina: 再把我这陀
Katrina: Take this lump of mine
Jake:这该怎么下口呢
Jake: How should I eat this?
Alice:先舔一下
Alice: Lick it first
Katrina: 扭一扭舔一舔
Katrina: Twist it, lick it
Jake:泡一泡
Jake: Dip it
Tasha: 其实需要勺子
Tasha: Actually, you need a spoon
Jake:结果没有
Jake: But there isn't one
Jake:那就硬吃是吧
Jake: So we just force it down, right?
Lucia: 嗯好好吃
Lucia: Mm, it's really good.
Lucia: 这个奶油调的也好好
Lucia: This cream is also really well made.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm.
Jake:第一视角是是是巨石阵
Jake: The first-person view is, is, is Stonehenge.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Mm.
Jake:眼线先吃
Jake: Eat the eyeliner first.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 好敬业哈哈哈
Lucia: So dedicated, hahaha.
Lucia: 我应该怎样才能把它撕开
Lucia: How should I tear it open?
Lucia: 哎呦吓我一跳
Lucia: Oh, you scared me!
Alice:哎楼下这个厕所门是坏的
Alice: Hey, the bathroom door downstairs is broken.
Alice:还是上面的坏的
Alice: Or is it the one upstairs that's broken?
Lucia: 好像俩都是坏的
Lucia: Seems like both are broken.
Katrina: 是好的呀
Katrina: No, it's fine.
Katrina: 哪坏了
Katrina: What's broken?
Alice:就锁不了
Alice: It just can't lock.
Jake:就那个是好的应该
Jake: That one should be fine.
Alice:那洗澡的话
Alice: What about for taking a shower?
Katrina: 楼上的楼上的这个是好的
Katrina: The one upstairs, this one is fine.
Lucia: 哦不这个是坏的
Lucia: Oh no, this one is broken.
Katrina: 我可以锁上
Katrina: I can lock it.
Lucia: 啊这个吗
Lucia: This one?
Katrina: 嗯就把他那个一拨一下就好
Katrina: Mm, just toggle it, and it's good.
Lucia: 你说的是这边这个还是那边那个
Lucia: Are you talking about this side or that side?
Katrina: 我你房间那个啊
Katrina: The one in your room.
Alice:这个是好的吗
Alice: Is this one working?
Lucia: 那个是好的那个好像
Lucia: That one seems to be working.
Lucia: 反正我没锁上
Lucia: Anyway, I didn't lock it.
Lucia: 也可能是我操作有误
Lucia: Maybe I operated it wrong.
Jake:哎呀  完了
Jake: Oh no, it's over.
Katrina: 他不是往左还是往右
Katrina: Doesn't it turn left or right?
Katrina: 拨一下就可以锁上
Katrina: Toggle it and it can lock.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Katrina: 3秒钟过了
Katrina: 3 seconds are up.
Jake:完了
Jake: It's over.
Alice:你可以从外面打开一下吗
Alice: Can you open it from the outside?
Alice:我看能锁上没
Alice: Let me see if it can lock.
Jake:这个应该不行
Jake: This one probably can't.
Jake:我理解算了吧
Jake: I think we should just forget about it.
Alice:嗯锁不了
Alice: Hmm, can't lock it.
Alice:坏一点
Alice: It's a bit broken.
Katrina: 你看我眼睛上的彩虹
Katrina: Look at the rainbow on my eyes.
Lucia: 哈哈不是你烤的吗
Lucia: Haha, didn't you bake it?
Lucia: 大家一起烤的
Lucia: Everyone baked it together.
Lucia: 关键还是有你的指导和经验烤的
Lucia: The key is still your guidance and experience in baking.
Lucia: 鼓掌哈哈哈
Lucia: Let's give a round of applause, hahaha.
Jake:鼓掌
Jake: Applause.
Tasha: 明天可以做进阶版的
Tasha: Tomorrow, we can make an advanced version.
Tasha: 就是他吃了之后会爆浆里面哦
Tasha: When you eat it, it'll have a gooey filling inside.
Lucia: 这么酷哈哈哈我以为
Lucia: That's so cool, hahaha. I thought...
Lucia: 我一直以为
Lucia: I always thought...
Lucia: 这种东西
Lucia: This kind of thing...
Lucia: 就是只有蛋糕店才可以做出来
Lucia: could only be made in a cake shop.
Lucia: 就是单靠个人的力量是做不出来的
Lucia: That you couldn't make it on your own.
Lucia: 哈哈只有一种神秘力量才能做出来
Lucia: Haha, only some kind of mysterious power can make it.
Jake:我们的
Jake: Our...
Lucia: 我们的神秘力量
Lucia: Our mysterious power.
Alice:我吃过两个
Alice: I've eaten two.
Katrina: 等一会等一会吃嘛
Katrina: Wait a bit, wait a bit, let's eat later.
Katrina: 我等一会就会消化
Katrina: I'll digest it in a bit.
Alice:谁没吃过两个
Alice: Who hasn't eaten two?
Lucia: 我还没吃过两个
Lucia: I haven't eaten two yet.
Katrina: 我还没吃过两个
Katrina: I haven't eaten two yet.
Tasha: 他还没吃啊
Tasha: He hasn't eaten yet.
Jake:啊我怎么没吃
Jake: Huh, how come I didn't eat?
Jake:我刚吃完就没吃
Jake: I just finished eating, so I didn't eat more.
Jake:哪个是我的
Jake: Which one is mine?
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Hey.
Katrina: 谁看见我线了
Katrina: Did anyone see my cable?
Katrina: 就剩一个头了
Katrina: There's only the head left.
Jake:什么线嗯
Jake: What cable?
Jake:iPhone的线吗
Jake: The iPhone cable?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake:iPhone的线
Jake: The iPhone cable.
Alice:嗯致死量的糖
Alice:快晕过去了
Alice:被你甜晕了
Alice:哈哈哈你的甜蜜攻击
Jake:哈哈哈
Tasha: 好好好
Tasha: Okay, okay, okay
Alice:俘获我的心
Alice: Capturing my heart
Alice:哈哈好好好
Alice: Haha, okay, okay, okay
Alice:我今天晚上想洗个澡
Alice: I want to take a shower tonight
Tasha: 你要不要去楼上洗
Tasha: Do you want to shower upstairs?
Jake:喂他我
Jake: Feed me
Jake:我给你看一下
Jake: Let me show you
Jake:那是不是你
Jake: Is that you?
Alice:开了灯有有声音的话应该也没人进
Alice: If the lights are on and there's noise, no one should come in
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Katrina: 你去去楼上洗呗
Katrina: You should go shower upstairs
Lucia: 楼上全是女生没事
Lucia: It's all girls upstairs, it's fine
Alice:明天不想化妆了
Alice: I don't want to wear makeup tomorrow
Alice:化妆好累还得卸
Alice: Putting on makeup is tiring and I have to remove it
Alice:我现在这样躺床上睡觉
Alice: I'll just lay in bed and sleep like this now
Katrina: 你们一般几点睡
Katrina: What time do you usually sleep?
Alice:我昨天3点多睡的
Alice: I slept around 3 AM yesterday
Tasha: 他每天只需要睡4个小时
Alice:no那是以前
Alice: No, that was before
Jake:应该是你的摸错了是吧
Jake: Maybe you touched the wrong one?
Katrina: 不是我是那个苹果壳
Katrina: No, I'm talking about the Apple case
Katrina: 哎哎哎苹果壳在这我试试
Katrina: Hey, hey, the Apple case is here, let me try
Jake:明天还要买什么呀
Jake: What else do we need to buy tomorrow?
Katrina: 不用买呀
Katrina: We don't need to buy anything
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Katrina: 停止外送旺仔牛奶
Katrina: Stop ordering Wangzai milk delivery
Katrina: 这两个34记得下单
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Katrina: 时钟你买是吧
Katrina: You're buying the clock, right?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Katrina: 这个我买了
Katrina: I bought this one
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Katrina: 234 他买就行
Katrina: He can just buy 234
Alice:今晚上是不是又要看那个装修
Alice: Are we watching that decoration thing again tonight?
Alice:装 不 装饰
Alice: Dec- No, decoration
Katrina: 还要看一下跳什么舞
Katrina: We also need to see what dance to do
Jake:嗯对跳跳舞
Jake: Yeah, let's dance
Alice:装饰的
Alice: The decoration one
Jake:装饰的装饰一下
Jake: Yeah, just decorate it a bit
Jake:装饰
Jake: Decorate
Alice:我想跟你睡一起了
Alice: I want to sleep with you.
Alice:我可以抄你的装饰
Alice: Can I copy your decorations?
Jake:装饰
Jake: Decorations.
Lucia: 我刚才也在想
Lucia: I was just thinking about that too.
Jake:装修的话
Jake: When it comes to renovations...
Lucia: 有没有哪位同学把自己的房间装修
Lucia: Has any classmate renovated their room?
Lucia: 给我抄一抄
Lucia: Let me copy it.
Jake:哈哈对
Jake: Haha, yeah.
Jake:装修可能讨论讨论
Jake: Maybe discuss renovations.
Katrina: 小红书照着买吧
Katrina: Just buy according to Xiaohongshu.
Jake:就是多开个PPT开个投影
Jake: Just open a PPT and a projector.
Jake:聊聊天看看图之类的啊
Jake: Chat, look at pictures, stuff like that.
Alice:啊看看组
Alice: Ah, look at the group.
Jake:是看看图看看图
Jake: Yes, look at pictures, look at pictures.
Jake:刷刷网页
Jake: Browse some websites.
Alice:是自己的房间吗
Alice: Is it for our own rooms?
Jake:对啊互相扯扯
Jake: Yeah, we can chat about it.
Jake:就是就互相扯扯
Jake: Just chat about it.
Lucia: 我们做完设计以后还要做一个PPT
Lucia: After we finish the design, we need to make a PPT?
Lucia: 向大家汇报一下吗
Lucia: To report to everyone?
Jake:呃PPT不用做
Jake: Uh, no need for a PPT.
Jake:就看网页就好了
Jake: Just browse the web.
Katrina: 看网页
Katrina: Browse the web.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Katrina: 直接用这个
Katrina: Just use this.
Katrina: 看手机不就行了
Katrina: Can't we just use our phones?
Jake:哦也对
Jake: Oh, that's true.
Jake:就是手机互相传阅是吧
Jake: Just pass the phone around, right?
Katrina: 为什么要看别人的
Katrina: Why look at others?
Jake:你自己看是吧
Jake: You look yourself, right?
Katrina: 嗯嗯
Katrina: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:哦你们要偷偷的自己搞
Jake: Oh, you want to secretly work on it yourself.
Jake:不跟别人分享
Jake: Without sharing with others.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Alice:那我的原来花里胡哨乱搞风
Alice: My original style was all flashy and chaotic.
Jake:你原来是
Jake: You used to be...
Jake:应该是
Jake: Should be...
Katrina: 倒也不是
Katrina: Not really.
Katrina: 我也是我要搞五颜六色
Katrina: I also want to make it colorful.
Lucia: 可是墙上不能贴的话
Lucia: But if we can't put anything on the walls...
Lucia: 我在想我应该怎么弄
Katrina: 美文纸明天叫个外送看看
Katrina: Maybe we can order some fancy paper tomorrow and check it out.
Katrina: 如果他要是真的效果挺好的话就可以
Katrina: If it turns out to be really good, we can go with it.
Jake:你们都吃完了
Jake: Have you all finished eating?
Jake:就剩我一个了
Jake: Am I the only one left?
Katrina: 我我还有一个
Katrina: I still have one more.
Katrina: 我等会我等会
Katrina: Wait, wait.
Katrina: 工作一会我又饿了
Katrina: I got hungry again after working a bit.
Jake:对工作工作
Jake: Yeah, work, work.
Katrina: 就是现在还没有消化
Katrina: I haven't digested yet.
Katrina: 我是那种吃的很少
Katrina: I eat very little.
Katrina: 但是我就是呃
Katrina: But I get full quickly too.
Katrina: 吃的少但是也饱的快
Katrina: I eat a little but get full fast.
Katrina: 饱的快马上又又饿了
Alice:小鸟胃
Alice: Bird's stomach.
Katrina: 饿的也快
Katrina: I get hungry quickly too.
Alice:小鸟胃
Alice: Bird's stomach.
Lucia: 好难想啊
Lucia: This is so hard to figure out.
Alice:好折磨我呀
Alice: This is torturing me.
Lucia: 为什么我们突然播出了这个环节呢
Lucia: Why did we suddenly start this segment?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:我看一下
Jake: Let me check.
Jake:我们用完之后
Jake: After we finish using it,
Alice:用完之后没
Alice: After we finish using it, what?
Jake:我们的计划
Jake: Our plan
Alice:接东西
Alice: Pick up things
Jake:我们给你们的保底计划
Jake: The backup plan we gave you
Jake:我们原来是说我们会出一个方案
Jake: We originally said we would come up with a plan
Jake:然后如果你们这个方案能你
Jake: And if you can make this plan work,
Jake:你们能整个挪活的话
Jake: Then use your plan.
Jake:那就用你们的方案
Jake: We'll try to make it work.
Jake:就是我们尽量的整活
Jake: We'll try our best.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Katrina: 啊 出去玩去吧
Katrina: Ah, let's go out and have fun.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Alice:那这些东西
Alice: And these things...
Alice:扔哪去什么这些
Alice: Where should we throw these?
Alice:就是用完之后的
Alice: Like after we finish using them,
Alice:没用完的
Alice: and the ones we haven't used.
Lucia: 好饱啊哈哈哈
Lucia: I'm so full, hahaha.
Lucia: 你好呀
Lucia: 哈哈突然出现啊
Lucia: Haha, you appeared suddenly!
Alice:被你吓了一跳
Alice: You scared me!
Katrina: 挑一挑
Katrina: Just picking something.
Lucia: 不好意思
Lucia: Sorry.
Lucia: 因为懒得把这挪走
Lucia: I was too lazy to move this.
Lucia: 就直接坐在这个小马上了
Lucia: So I just sat on this little horse.
Alice:是不是该刷碗了
Alice: Shouldn't we be washing the dishes?
Alice:好痛苦啊
Alice: It's such a pain.
Alice:真读假读
Alice:我们外卖还没扔呢
Alice: We haven't thrown out the takeout yet.
Lucia: 哦对我们剩的外卖还没有收拾
Lucia: Oh right, we haven't cleaned up the leftover takeout.
Alice:上边的
Alice: On top of it.
Alice:还没收拾
Alice: Haven't cleaned up yet.
Jake:啊什么东西
Jake: Ah, what's that?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:什么东西
Jake: What's that?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:啥啥
Jake: What, what?
Jake:是啊什么东西
Jake: Yeah, what's that?
Lucia: 什么呀
Lucia: What?
Jake:是啥呀
Jake: What is it?
Lucia: 哈哈哈打哑谜洗了
Lucia: Hahaha, playing riddles, huh?
Jake:哦哦哦哈哈好行
Jake: Oh oh oh, haha okay fine.
Jake:我们给你们
Jake: We'll give you guys...
Jake:我们有一些proposal
Jake: We have some proposals.
Jake:一个是
Jake: One is...
Lucia: 说来听听
Lucia: Let's hear it.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:嗯也不是
Jake: Hmm, not really.
Jake:就是这中间几天怎么整活了
Jake: Just how to keep things lively these days.
Jake:一些proposal
Jake: Some proposals.
Alice:哎眼镜呢
Alice: Hey, where are my glasses?
Lucia: 给我们一些灵感嘛
Lucia: Give us some inspiration.
Lucia: 说不定我们听了之后会有更多的ID的
Lucia: Maybe after hearing it, we'll have more ideas.
Jake:你的眼镜好了
Jake: Your glasses are fixed.
Katrina: 我的风铃挂在哪里呢
Katrina: Where should I hang my wind chime?
Lucia: 网好差呀
Lucia: The internet is so bad.
Lucia: 刷不出东西
Lucia: Can't load anything.
Jake:哎老三呢
Jake: Hey, where's the third one?
Alice:上楼了拿东西去
Alice: Going upstairs to get something.
Jake:这是他手机
Jake: This is his phone.
Lucia: 是的
Lucia: Yes.
Jake:你给他带上
Jake: Give it to him.
Lucia: 咱这有洗衣机吗
Lucia: Do we have a washing machine here?
Jake:有就在那边
Jake: Yes, it's over there.
Lucia: 看看这个
Lucia: Look at this.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 啊他前面被堵住了
Lucia: Ah, it's blocked in front.
Lucia: 门口应该有个灯
Lucia: There should be a light at the door.
Lucia: 让我研究一下
Lucia: Let me figure it out.
Lucia: 咱们需要洗衣服的数据吗
Lucia: Do we need the laundry data?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:呃可以有
Jake: Um, we can have it.
Jake:可以洗
Jake: You can wash it.
Lucia: 因为我想把我这个裤子洗一下
Lucia: Because I want to wash these pants.
Lucia: 不过我光手洗一下
Lucia: But I'll just hand wash it.
Lucia: 那个沾到沾到奶油的地方
Lucia: The part with the cream stain.
Jake:那也可以用它 对
Jake: You can use it too, yeah.
Lucia: 或者就是直接撂进去
Lucia: Or just throw it in directly.
Lucia: 他这有洗衣液
Lucia: There's detergent here.
Lucia: 哎还真有
Lucia: Oh, there really is.
Jake:有
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 啊好全啊
Lucia: Ah, so well-equipped.
Lucia: 嗯啊
Lucia: Hmm, ah.
Katrina: 我想想
Katrina: Let me think.
Lucia: 那我又要上去一下了
Lucia: Then I'll go up again.
Lucia: 让我换个裤子就下来
Lucia: I'll change my pants and come down.
Jake:有一个火锅抽奖   抽食材
Jake: There's a hotpot lottery, draw the ingredients.
Jake:抽到什么吃什么
Jake:哈哈就是这个意思
Jake: Haha, that's the idea.
Alice:你的眼镜好了
Alice: Your glasses are ready.
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Alice:me
Alice: Me.
Katrina: 这也是要自己做的这个
Katrina: This also needs to be done by yourself.
Lucia: 来观摩一下什么
Lucia: Here to observe what?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia: 来观摩一下你打算怎么改造你的房间
Lucia: Here to observe how you plan to renovate your room.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh my.
Katrina: 设计专业的
Katrina: Design major
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Lucia: 哈哈procreate
Jake:完了你设计完估计还要做president大家
Jake: After you finish designing, you might need to become the president.
Alice:什么president
Alice: What president?
Katrina: 别吓唬他
Katrina: Don't scare him.
Jake:就是要
Jake: You really have to.
Jake:呃修硕 给你讲一遍
Jake: Uh, Shure, explain it to him.
Jake:就是秀硕把你的房间帮你讲一遍
Jake: Shure, explain your room to him.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Jake:哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha, ah
Jake:没有没有没有乱说
Jake: No, no, just kidding.
Lucia: 我们还有这个环节
Lucia: We have this segment too?
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake:就是我是说
Jake: I mean...
Jake:他可能最后能做出个视频出来
Jake: He might end up making a video in the end.